I am the things have changed since you  film an applied Quixote in stellar life  would you like to see don't go to the  Romana Chuck I do  [Music]  you crazy peasant you think you can hide  from me we shall have such a great  adventures together de la mancha come to  restore the lost age of chivalry well I  wrote that can I read this isn't like  you sound the words and you can look at  the pictures how he actually believes  he's done guilty this is going to be huh  [Music]  saint-just you've read to my exploits Oh  Castle is reading them but you made me a  promise I could be someone you could be  someone a star [ __ ] go try to give up  the process of the party needs constant  entertainment  I command you to release my swirl this  has nothing to do thing why does  everything always have to be about you  [Music]  you